at the beginning of the pandemic like
everyone else i was hearing lots about
viruses but realized i didn't really
know that much about what they
are so i did a load of research and have
summarized what i learnt in these nine
images okay let's get into it viruses
are the most abundant form of life on
earth
but are they life not really they can't
reproduce on their own so they have to
invade other cells to take over their
molecular machinery
to reproduce using the steps shown here
which i'll go into more detail later
there's an unknown number of different
kinds of virus definitely in the
millions if not higher
but only about 6 000 have been studied
in detail
they vary wildly invading all kinds of
cells animals plants bacteria and
archaea and none of them work in
precisely the same way
despite this bewildering range it's
possible to make some categorizations
although
please be aware that there are
exceptions to any category that i'm
defining
that's the nature of any subject as
complex as virology
with that in mind viruses always contain
a genome
the instructions for making more viruses
and a protective shell made of proteins
called a capsid
which keeps the virus safe and helps the
virus stick to and enter the cells
they're invading
some viruses are also coated in an
envelope a greasy cover
taken from the membrane of the last cell
they infected
viruses are incredibly small for example
an average human cell is a bit smaller
than a tenth of a millimeter or a
hundred micrometers
and viruses around a thousand times
smaller than that
ranging from around 20 nanometers
upwards
here are a few virus particles drawn to
scale hepatitis a hepatitis c
coronavirus influenza hiv and the
humongous
ebola virus for some viruses their
genome is really small coding for just
two proteins
but other viruses code for up to 2 500
proteins for the largest genomes
there are a few ways to classify viruses
the genome of a virus is either based on
dna or rna and is either single stranded
or double stranded
viruses come in a wide range of shapes
the capsid of viruses are made from many
of the same shaped proteins that
self-assemble into different shapes like
helical which is a spiral
icosahedral made of shapes like
triangles or hexagons or pentagons to
make a shape like a 20-sided dice or a
soccer ball
prolate which is the same kind of thing
but stretched out
complex which covers a wide range of
viruses that don't fit into the other
categories
and finally enveloped viruses which we
mentioned earlier
there's a scientific way to classify
viruses by following the official
taxonomy
another useful classification technique
is the baltimore classification which
looks at the genome of a virus and its
pathway to encoding messenger
rna or mrna which is a single stranded
molecule that the host cell
uses to make the virus proteins
there are seven classes in the baltimore
classification which represent
different forms of single and
double-stranded dna and rna
for an example let's look at the
coronavirus that caused the 2020
pandemic
it's an envelope virus meaning that it's
very vulnerable to soap which rips off
the outer protective coat
destroying it which is why we've been
told to wash our hands so often
and in the baltimore classification it's
a class iv virus which is a type of
single stranded rna virus
interestingly this is different to
seasonal flu which is a class 5
virus so the two are not related
now let's look in a bit more detail
about how viruses get into cells
how they reproduce and how they get back
out again
there are three main ways viruses get
their genetic material into a cell
envelope viruses attach to receptors on
the surface of the cell which then fuses
with the membrane
remember they're made out of the same
stuff because the virus took its
envelope from the last cell it was in
so the new cell doesn't see that it's an
invader
viruses without an envelope essentially
trick the cell into thinking that the
virus is a harmless resource like
nutrition
and engulfs it this is called
endocytosis and viruses with an envelope
can enter the cell this way too
this virus then has to break out of this
vesicle to release its genetic material
a less common method of entering a cell
is genetic injection where the virus
punches a hole into the cell membrane
and directly injects its genetic
material into the cell
bacteriophages do this to bacteria but
not to human cells
replication is a very complex process so
i'm having to break it down into perhaps
an overly simplistic description but
at least it's a start in general rna
viruses replicate in the cell cytoplasm
and dna viruses replicate in the cell's
nucleus but there are exceptions to this
the host cell then starts transcribing
the viral genetic material without
knowing that it's not native to the cell
the virus codes for essentially two
things an enzyme called polymerase
and proteins which form the capsid shell
polymerase creates
copies of the viral genome this is also
when mutations can happen to the virus
in general viruses mutate very fast rna
viruses more quickly than dna viruses
because rna is inherently
less stable than dna these mutations are
random most having little effect on the
virus but sometimes they can make the
virus more dangerous or less dangerous
to the host
the capsid proteins self-assemble from a
couple of simple shapes they can form
large complicated three-dimensional
structures
which enclose copies of the genetic
material inside
to form a new virus particle ready to
leave the cell
it's worth mentioning retroviruses which
are a type of virus that insert their
viral dna
into the dna of their host this has
happened a lot through
our evolutionary history and in fact
viral dna sequences make up eight
percent of our genome
a lot of which we share with our common
ancestors
there are three ways viruses leave cells
apoptosis results in the death of the
cell through a self-destruct mechanism
the viruses either burst out as shown
here
or more usually the cell death is a more
controlled process where sections clump
off to be absorbed
by other cells like macrophages budding
is where the virus exits the cell taking
with it an envelope of the cell's
membrane
this doesn't kill the cell but it will
degrade it over time and eventually lead
to the cell's death
a kind of opposite process is exocytosis
where the virus has an
envelope inside the cell which it got
from the nucleus membrane or another
membrane in the cell
then the virus exits through the cell
wall leaving this membrane behind
and this doesn't kill the cell i should
also mention that some viruses can stay
dormant inside cells for years at a time
which is called latency
so that's how viruses invade cells now
let's zoom out and look at a broader
picture of viral infections
the range of a virus is how many
different kinds of organisms
the virus can infect plant viruses don't
infect animals and most animal viruses
can't infect humans
in most cases viruses are adapted to a
single species
but some like rabies have a larger range
and others can cross over to other
species when they mutate
if we look at humans we can group
viruses into those that have been with
us for a long time
and those which have recently crossed
over equilibrium viruses have had a long
time to adapt to our biology so tends
not to be lethal to us
after all it's more effective for the
virus to keep us alive to infect other
people
rather than killing us non-equilibrium
viruses are a lot more dangerous because
the virus has not yet adapted to our
biology
so the mortality rate for these
infections is a lot higher as different
people's immune systems reacts to them
in many different ways
here are some examples of
non-equilibrium viruses including of
course the coronavirus pandemic that
we're currently experiencing
influenza has got a segmented genome a
genome in many parts
which means that different strains can
swap genes if they infect the same host
this means that they're more likely to
cross over species and is called
antigenic shift
which is what happened in the 2009 h1n1
epidemic
our bodies have got sophisticated
mechanisms to detect and destroy
viral infections it starts when a virus
is ingested by an antigen presenting
cell which breaks it down and displays
portions of the virus to activate
t helper cells the t helper cells then
activate two responses to the virus
b cells produce antibodies that are
targeted at the specific virus
these antibodies bind to the outer
surface of the virus neutralizing it
they also tag the virus to be destroyed
if it enters a cell by
enzymes within the cell cells in our
body continually display what proteins
they have inside them
on their surface if a cytotoxic t cell
recognizes a viral protein on the
surface of an infected cell
it will go and destroy that cell our
bodies b
and t cells keep a memory of the virus
which can make us immune to future
infections from that specific virus but
this immunity wears off over time
sometimes this immunity lasts for many
years but other times like for the
viruses that cause the common cold and
the flu
our immunity is not very good because of
the high variability of the viruses or
because our antibody response is poor
vaccines are incredibly effective ways
of preventing viral infections
it's possible to completely eradicate
viral infections from human equilibrium
viruses
which we've managed to do with smallpox
and is possible with polio
measles mumps and rubella if only people
would listen
vaccines contain a modified form of the
virus that's been weakened in some way
so that they no longer cause an
infection but they do stimulate
an immune response teaching our immune
system how to recognize the virus
and where there's no vaccine antiviral
drugs can be used to treat viral
infections
although development of these drugs is
difficult because they can only target a
specific virus which
are continually mutating one example of
an antiviral technique are drugs that
fool the virus into incorporating dummy
dna into their genomes which stops them
from having the instructions to
replicate anymore
so that covers everything i wanted to
talk about if you want to find out more
there are a bunch of links in the video
description you'll also find a link to
this image which i'd love for you to
share around the internet
as well as this video i think the more
people who get access to good
information about
viruses right now the better this
content wouldn't be possible without the
support of my patrons
and people buying posters so if you'd
like to help out please
consider it i hope you're all doing okay
and i'll see you with more
science soon